hi this is nasir from nas daily welcome
back to the iced coffee hour so far i
believe this podcast has generated over
four hundred thousand dollars in ad
revenue
it keeps going higher every time yeah no
so what are we making about 155 155
yeah man there was a long period of time
we were not making that much money at
all like just like a few hundred dollars
or a few thousand dollars i'm guessing
you made 30k at least in the last month
in ad revenue yeah 20. yeah it's like
19. for a podcast on the side come on
that's not bad it's not bad at all yeah
so thank you so much for coming on this
siren it's great to have you on we've
been planning this out since september
since september we've been wanting to
have you on so thanks for coming on i've
been wanting to come here and talk to
you guys in depth for a while hopefully
we can make good tv i think so jack if
you want to do the intro yes so this is
nasir from nos daily he is as some
people say the mr beast of facebook he's
got over 40 million says that i don't
know i heard it at vidsummit that's
funny do you agree or do you i've never
heard of that you've never heard of that
is that a compliment
we make different content
he's great but we make different content
well by that i think it means like you
know tycoon or the boss man got it
exactly of facebook you have over 40
million followers across all platforms
and overall a great friend and a great
guy thank you man sweet thank you how
did i introduce jack yesterday can you
tell them
how did you how did i remember how i
introduced him you said i was actually
my my memory is so bad oh great remember
how did you introduce you we had a
dinner last night that's why you're here
and you should have been late jack we
had i did show up later i'm so sorry the
uber was taking forever but we uh there
was a dinner last night that you hosted
a creator dinner here in las vegas
across from the wynn
and uh a bunch of finance creators and
you were there as well and you
introduced everyone around the table and
you introduced me i think if i'm
remembering correctly as like the
attractive co-host or something the most
the most attractive
yeah that was tough
tough well thank you yeah
anyway so yes you are our most
attractive guest thank you that is a lie
so we have to get on to the finances of
it all right
how much money are you making you said
right before we right before we film
this podcast that that is the hook let's
get into it yeah and you said you were
gonna be surprised because you're like
it's a lot less than you think i i
definitely make a lot less than most
people think so let's start here so 40
million followers across all 47 42
sorry it's only 7 million people the
population of israel 47 million people
how many views does that translate to
every month
we
get
550 million views per month across the
platforms across platforms yes jeez
i'm going to say there's no way that's
less than 300 000 a month you can't you
can add revenue
well yeah i mean yeah we can't just just
say one or the other i would say yeah ad
revenue no i had revenue under 100 100
000. no 150 that's my guess well he's
good ad revenue he's good yeah how much
do you think nas
daily makes million a month wow yeah i
would say
well are we talking net or gross
uh just gross gross yeah i would say
like
1.3 a month wow
man if i was making 1.3 million a month
i'd be staying in the wind not at the
conrad wow
um okay so so so the way the way it
nasty works is that you know we have 47
million followers let's say 500 million
views but 200 million of these views are
non-monetizable
because there are youtube shorts so you
make 10k from that then you have another
let's say
50 million views on tick tock and
instagram that's non-monetizable
so really the monetizable views and then
we have another 100 million views that
are in vietnam and indonesia and spanish
and arabic
very low cpm
so really uh you know there's only like
50 million views that are actually
monetizable per month wow
for us because i index not on money i
index on distribution i care a lot about
the vws not the usd
you know the vws views currency is
really important
so uh it's kind of complicated thinking
about how much nas daily makes to be
honest with you i don't track it very
well i'm not a i'm not a i'm not i'm not
good with with finance
but there's a lot of different sources
of revenue so ad revenue for us is
20
of what we do it's never been something
i've indexed on
uh a lot of our revenue comes from
production deals uh from nasa academy
from government brand deals uh and from
uh tourism boards and and this stuff uh
so we actually are
i'll give you the combined everything
everything
like nasa academy and nas daily nos
group
nas group probably makes
i should have got the number before you
just give us a ballpark uh a ballpark is
probably like 900 or something like that
okay nine hundred thousand dollars a
month something like that yeah so we
were close we were really close you were
very close
i bet a lot of that's from the academy
so it's probably half half okay
probably half half yeah
400 400 500 500 something like that so
if i could access ask a question just
because i'm a little bit confused here
what kind of videos are you making to
make this sort of income because i've
never watched your videos um to be
honest what the hell are you doing here
get out of here how rude you know to be
fair jack called me 20 minutes before
this podcast and he's like alex get over
here
but yeah if we could go maybe into a
little detail of what kind of videos
you're making because i'm sure
everybody's curious
so the videos we make are are nas means
people in arabic so it's it's not daily
people daily i didn't know that i had no
idea oh jesus christ it's the
[ __ ] cover photo of facebook and
youtube channels
god maybe i should become a finance
creator for you guys to give a [ __ ]
about me
it's like
i'll tell you about my favorite i
watched i researched this this morning
listen to a podcast you were on
which one uh collins mirror oh nice nice
yeah um
yeah so so so i go around the world my
team and i go around the world and find
the most interesting people and the most
interesting places and we just make
videos about them it's as simple as that
this person in cambodia has 12 speaks 12
languages this person in hong kong looks
like tarzan this person is the richest
you know uh uh billionaire in the world
under the age of 30. you know these are
like there's a lot of inspiring people
around the world our job is to turn
their story into a video
that's it you'd be surprised
how few people how few videos exist in
the world in this in this industry
that's fascinating
you know what's interesting too is that
i had actually never heard of you until
vid summit jesus christ because you're
white i had exactly but the thing is
that you're like
exactly your american audience like you
don't have much of an american audience
for the amount of views that you get
only one percent of the country follows
nasa no yes
we have like three to four million
followers hundreds of millions of views
a month yeah here in america people
don't necessarily recognize you but
you're why
because some of this content like the
bitcoin content that was one of my
favorite videos that you did that
interview um which one the bitcoin
millionaire oh yeah the billionaire yeah
yeah
yeah
why doesn't that get pushed to a u.s
audience well first of all it's because
of the platform you choose so facebook
is actually 95
international only five percent of
facebook audience is american so if
you're big on facebook you're gonna be
big wherever facebook is big
and facebook is huge in india it's huge
in philippines it's huge in bangladesh
huge in pakistan right and and the
middle east
facebook is nothing in sweden
so because of that we were just sucked
into the east and honestly i like it
because the east also deserves the same
content that somebody in vegas deserves
right so it's a
like content equality so it's it's
really important then i think we started
youtube uh a year and a half ago and
like two years ago yeah and that's where
we started to get a lot more american
audience uh so on facebook out of the
you know 35
facebook followers we have like let's
say three million ten percent uh and
then on youtube it's the number one
country it's like 20 25 but it's very
low right you're 85
25 of our content is is american i think
it also boils down to the idea that
americans love themselves
they just [ __ ] love themselves right
it's like
i only care about basketball or baseball
or american football you know how many
people give a [ __ ] about american
football in germany zero
you know so i also give zero shits about
nfl
so
why would we ever make videos about that
so we never make videos about american
topics i think that's probably why as
well gosh that makes sense how do you
find these people i'm so curious and
what was the first person that you
featured and lastly i'm curious how many
offers do you get from people wanting to
pay you to feature them
a lot
so the first time i made a video about a
human was on day 300. so the way nas
daily worked out is i committed to
making a thousand videos in a thousand
days that was like the biggest hardest
most you know ridiculous thing i've done
in my life three and a half years of
daily video making on facebook not
youtube i was anti-youtube back then
um and in the first 300 days i was
training on how to make videos and i was
pointing the camera at myself
but at some point i realized i should
point the camera at others and that's
when things started to go viral so it
was some guy in the philippines who
invented some some you know uh uh uh you
know non-profit thing i would say um
the way we find ideas is every country i
go to i create a meet-up so a meetup is
basically i put on facebook or youtube
say i am going to be in peru
if you like nas daily and want to be in
the video come at this place at this
time
in in china 20 people come
in the philippines 4 000 people come wow
you know it really depends on the
country and america probably will get
500 or so it depends on the country and
how big nice daily is in that country
and then i have 500 or a thousand locals
and i literally just ask them who is
interesting in your country
who should we profile
give me your your mother your
grandfather your uncle somebody you
heard about in local news so we
literally do like investigative
journalism to find ideas that new york
times has never found
and i'll tell this to everybody i look
at the camera if anybody wants to feel
like christopher columbus
it's too late to feel like christopher
columbus as a discoverer right sure like
we've discovered every piece of land in
the world but if you want to feel like
christopher columbus start making videos
and go to places that nobody cares about
and make videos about the people there
you'll be the first person in the world
to make that video and tell that story
to the outside world and it's kind of
like you discovered a new story and
there's a lot of meaning in that it's
fascinating
but first i want to thank our sponsor
grammarly jack do you have any new
year's resolutions well i'd like to go
on some more dates but i can't because
of my workload well if that's really the
only reason then why don't you get
grammarly then you can save a ton of
time and go on those supposed dates the
beginning of the new year can be a very
stressful time but thankfully
grammarly's ai-powered writing assistant
can help me shed a lot of wasted hours
finally giving me the chance to date all
of those girls that are practically
begging for their superman to show up
never say that again writing emails and
scripts have become incredibly time
consuming but ever since i got grammarly
i've been able to write more clearly and
mistake free in just a fraction of the
time concisely telling someone what i
need is crucial for keeping workflow
efficient and grammarly's natural
vocabulary suggestions have made that a
breeze and i especially love their tone
detector which prevents me from emailing
alex too informally so he wouldn't
forget who's boss dude you fired me and
stop flexing grammarly premium even has
a feature that will offer whole sentence
rewrites that will help make what i'm
saying more clear and less redundant so
say what you mean and speak in the tone
you're aiming for with grammarly premium
start the year off right with grammarly
and my listeners actually get 20 off
grammarly premium at grammarly.com
iced coffee that's g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash iced coffee for 20 off
thank you so much grammarly for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast so who's the first person
yeah um uh some guy in philippines who
invented like um
a way to create light out of like a
liter of light
uh he does like liter of flight you know
like you take a you take a bottle and
then you put in you can in many places
there's no electricity right so he would
find a way to create electricity out of
like an empty water bottle uh so that
was that was that was really cool and
just bringing electricity to people that
need it i was like wow that's great more
people should know about it
and was your first video a success
i saw signals of success
i saw on the first video about humans
yes nas daily failed for the first 270
videos
so the first 270 times i made videos it
was not a real success it was 100 000
followers on facebook zero money
you know averaging 10 000 views
yeah you know facebook views are also
you know three second views right as
youtubers would call them they're fake
um so it you cannot build a business on
top of that and so day 270 i made a
video it went super viral and nast daily
became what it is why did you make that
challenge to begin with why a thousand
videos a thousand days what were you
doing before that
yeah so i i'm a big believer before
making videos i was a software engineer
so i was working at venmo fintech this
this world i i found a lot of meaning in
enabling transactions between people and
you know that was a lot of fun
especially seeing venmo go from you know
nothing
to like
a 40 billion dollar company now is
insane you know
um
so so uh why did i make a thousand
videos because i believe that i'm not
the smartest person
the smartest people in the world only
need one shot at making a documentary it
gets picked up by netflix by canes the
whole world sees it
and they become big right that's the
smartest video makers
i'm not that so for me to succeed in
this world i need to work five times as
hard and iterate 50 times as much
so i believe that in 24 hours i can fix
my mistakes
all i need is 24 hours to fix a mistake
so if i made a mistake on day 100 310 i
can fix it on day 311
and that iterative sort of mindset that
that that i'm a big fan of uh enabled me
to become a better video maker
because i
tried and failed and succeeded a
thousand times
you quit your job at venmo to do this
yeah so i quit my job april 8th 2016. i
started nas daily april 9th 2016. you're
crazy for doing that
uh a little bit because i gave up my u.s
visa so my h-1b
yeah it's really difficult to get why
did you want to quit it seems like
working at vemmo was a it was a great
job
the dream opportunity i was making 120k
you know 120k i was single living in new
york my parents combined make 80k
so imagine making more than your parents
who've been working for 30 years and you
just graduated college yeah what the
[ __ ]
um
i think and this is this goes down to
the t-shirt right you know when i when i
was at venmo i was selling my time for
money you know basically i told venmo
i'll give you 365 days of my life and
you give me 120 000
the question is how much
is 365 days of your life worth
especially in your 20s
my price then was 500 000 right
everything has a price
my one year in my 20s because i'll never
get my 20s back is worth 500 000
and i just needed if venmo wasn't going
to pay that i needed to find something
that is worth 500 000 to me and that was
traveling and making videos and meeting
people and just like being out there you
know
going to papua new guinea going to
ethiopia going to kenya that's [ __ ]
amazing
um
so that's why that's why i had to leave
so i also calculated
what percentage of my life is done
so back then i was 24 24 i ca i asked
google
when am i going to die
turns out there's two people that know
when you're about to die god and google
google tells you you're about to die at
76 because you're male in the united
states
if you're female is 78
24 out of 76 was 32
when i realized i was one-third dead
of my life
i needed to spend the remaining
two-thirds of my life doing something
important something meaningful and ever
since then i've been wearing for the
last five [ __ ] years
i've been wearing the same t-shirt i was
about to say every time i've seen you
it's the same shirt does that every year
of your life or like do you calculate it
so then it's like forty percent yeah
forty one percent every eight months
so every eight months of your life and
my life is one percent of our lives
and i started nas daily at 32 percent
yeah so i've spent seven percent of my
life building nas daily and us academy
wow he's not expecting such a good
answer yeah that's incredible geez
so what do your parents think you're
turning away venmo
to make videos because that's what i
think most parents oh you're making
youtube videos
so when you of course i'm sure your
parents right
you know in the past five years ago this
is not a this is not a career especially
on facebook where there's no
monetization
but now
now i'm really rich
they love it
i've come to realize that parents
want two things for their
sons and daughters
rich money or fame
if you become famous your parents will
be happy with you
because the because parents care about
society what society thinks it's
especially in my community if society
thinks well of you we support you if
society doesn't think well of you or
what you're doing we don't support you
and so the minute i started to get a
million followers and started to get
some fame in back in israel they're like
we're supportive
when i made my first million dollars
even more supportive you know so
if you want to please your parents like
index on one of these two things now now
they love it now nas daily is
i think
the second most popular israeli
uh after gal gadot so gal gadot is
number one it's very difficult to
compete
uh but you know for for for them
and for me
it's more than just money and fame it's
you know i'm arab israeli i'm not jewish
and uh you know it's very difficult for
arab israelis to succeed in israel
and be you know known in the world stage
and so
uh
i think
for us for me specifically it's a lot
more meaningful than making money
and getting followers it's showing the
jews and the christians and the other
arabs that it is impossible for an arab
who is a second-class citizen to make it
big just as much as a jewish israeli you
know that's really important messaging
back home that i i want nice daily to to
to give
wow
that's really cool
270 videos in you have one that does
well what's that video
how cheap is thailand
it's all about money oh wow see here we
go it comes full circle back to the iced
coffee hour so how cheap is thailand
guys i'm in thailand and did you know
that this noodle cup is 30 cents this
hotel with a pool is 30
i can't believe it and for these prices
i'm going to buy a hundred meals in
thailand and have fun for 30 dollars
which is the cost of a cocktail in new
york
30 million views wow
you know what but everyone in the us
secretly
wishes they could go and do that if even
for a yes yes everybody
definitely i've seen those uh really
nice airbnbs where it's like yeah this
is 50 a night and it's got a pool it's
got a view it looks incredible like here
that would be like a thousand dollars a
night yes
make that content the cheapest and the
most expensive that content does super
well
yeah wow so when that video took off
how many more like it did you make
was that the sign that like okay now i
got to go to other countries and do this
too yeah yeah for that at that point it
was no return
no more looking for other jobs content
creation is possible as a career i was
100 000 followers before that video i
became 400 000 followers after that
video
one video was 4x
my last 270 days the beauty of the
internet is that it's not linear it
doesn't go
you know
either like step by step it goes step
step step step goes down goes down and
then goes up like that yeah
i love that how do you know that wasn't
just a one-off thing because i've seen
so many creators have a one-off video
just millions of views and they cannot
sustain it it just goes away well i knew
if i made how cheap is thailand i knew
there's 196 other countries
how cheap is philippines how chief is
uruguay how cheap is germany
you know so i knew that that content
could uh extend beyond just a one-off
um
i was confident of that got it yeah what
was the cheapest place now we gotta know
if you're gonna pick the cheapest place
for i would say the quality of life that
you get
so not necessarily like yeah you could
survive on a dollar a day but like this
is the best value for the cost well
uzbekistan is the cheapest place i've
ever been to in my life but not not a
high quality of life yet how cheap is it
there or like give us some examples of
like how much a meal a place to rent
what you get a transportation
like i mean i went to like the most
expensive restaurant and no meal was
about four dollars wow that was insane
i was shocked and what's the quality of
that like good really how would you
compare it to the us in terms of like a
like a restaurant is it like a
um you know
i don't know did you have quality or
like yeah i don't need meat
unfortunately
um
you know the us is i think there's a
restaurant to like compare it to i mean
i would say like the restaurant we went
to last night right wow like you you
could get the exact same every meal four
dollars max okay yeah
that's comparable yeah
but you know i so we went to like a like
a mexican restaurant last night um it
was good high quality yeah i was in the
strip so everything is inflated right so
i would say well i wouldn't say high
quality i would say yeah not high
quality
jack's a caliber of food it's very low
and clothing yeah
not joking no no no but jack goes to
this place what was it called the the
mexican place tony's mexican tony's
mexican it's good but they serve it to
you on like a lunch plate you know it's
good it's it's good food but it's
incredible what would you say the
quality of that is i would say quality
it's 11.99 for a chimichanga i would say
the
taste is great the quality is probably
less than medium like on a scale once
then it's probably a fourth one i kind
of have to trust graham on this one
wouldn't you agree with me on this
though because it's not about the money
that you're spending on the plate it's
about the experience right
yeah that's a very that's a very issue
what i don't like is that they do the
sour cream and they put the sour cream
in the bottle and they go shh
across the thing like that no that's not
good sour cream
it's pretty gross that's authentic okay
thank you alex in a bottle sour cream in
the bottle is it really
it's off if you're depending on what you
get like if you get enchiladas and stuff
to go
over it yes that's authentic how do you
know that
look at me man look at my skin tone man
come on bro i'm brown you're brown i
cannot make uh any assumptions on your
race
yeah but we're in america so 50 chance
if you're brown you're probably from the
south aka mexico you have mexico
well no i was born in illinois
wow there you go if i assumed you're
mexican you'd call me racist and you put
in the first 10 seconds of this video
but anyway my point is you can go to
like some some uh what are they taco
trucks or whatever and you'll get some
of the best food depending on where you
are so it really doesn't matter like
what it looks like or if they serve it
to you on a lunch plate
anyway my point being if i take jack to
danny's you'd be like this is like a
five star denny's is incredible
this is like three michelin star
restaurant come to dubai again i feel
like i'm in the tourism board come to
dubai because that's where there is
really good food singapore asia dennis
is crap
america by the way me and my personal
trainer like made a decision every time
i go to america like index to get three
more kilograms of fat because america
has no
healthy options
the big
ah i believe it let's so let's go back
on uh uzbekistan so you're saying four
dollars for a meal the meal in my
opinion would have been equivalent to
like you know a medium-tier mexican
restaurant here no no maybe maybe higher
higher okay maybe a little bit higher
yeah what about like transportation uh
lodging hotel house oh man i i don't i
don't remember to be honest with you but
i would say everything is everything is
like sub 50 like everything nothing is
like
you know nothing is like more than a 100
bucks i i mean in one way like i i
enjoyed making those videos but in
another way it's like
it's cheap for us but it's expensive for
them yes yeah what's the income there
because i think i think if we look at it
in proportion yes uh if you're spending
let's say twenty dollars a day six
hundred dollars a month yeah say or even
a thousand dollars a month i bet the
income would probably 500 500 yeah
that's the problem so maybe the you know
the big mac index like somebody
should find actually where is the
biggest purchasing power in the world
that would be by definition the cheapest
place
not oh this place is cheap if i'm a
swiss or an american tourist that cheap
this place is cheap for locals and
tourists alike that's true what is that
country i'd love to find that out yeah
you should find it yes i think that
would be interesting that's a viral
video yeah oh
the big mac index
yeah
okay this is good that's good now we got
content okay yeah thanks i like that
okay
um so besides that what would be the
cheapest would you say for the quality
that you get
you know i would i would highly
advise people to
um
look the guy next to you bro you you
guys never left america i just learned
that yesterday no i've been to canada
and i've been to mexico
i've been to i've been to canada too it
was on a connection
canada does not count it was vancouver
yeah yeah
i would advise everybody to like go to
the asia continent one and africa one
because asia is like sixty percent of
the world lives there
six out of ten humans is asian not
american actually american is less than
five percent so i think a lot of
a lot of countries there have like
really affordable pricing and good
quality living like you can look at bali
philippines and honestly dubai singapore
i mean
they've designed cities and countries
and infrastructure
south korea like they've designed
countries way better than than america
did but you just don't hear about it
that's the problem
so
what country is yeah
philippines i highly advise you visit
philippines okay it's the most
culturally similar to the united states
because you guys colonized it
for a while
and but so everybody speaks english
everybody's very friendly and it is uh
you know incredibly affordable and has
the best nature i've ever seen
second best but yeah
um philippines is the place to go and by
by the way you you if if you're building
a team i also advise you not just to
travel in the philippines and pay cheap
prices but also to hire from the
philippines
they are the most creative video editors
i've worked with in my life
and 40 percent of my team
the studios team is filipino
uh all my videos my best editor
not best but one of the best editors
is a 19 year old girl in the philippines
with no college education
and she just edits daily videos and
she's great how do you find her she
watches not standing really yeah so i
hire my community i hire my followers
basically
that's so cool and my students yeah
anybody takes my class i hire them
what's interesting to me is that you
have a plan you told me like your your
dream is to have a thousand employees
yeah and it's so funny because i draw
like
parallels between that and graham and
graham doesn't want to have anybody
really no no he's not the best
yeah it's just he was hesitant to hire
me he was hesitant to hire alex and he's
very satisfied even though he may be
working 60 to 70 hours a week he's very
satisfied just having two three
employees wow i would love to talk to
you i'm to interview you now all right
talk to me i'm a solo i'm a lone world
wolf when it comes to a lot of this why
what what what what's the motivation uh
i just like doing things myself i've
always just been you know i like i i've
never played in sports was never a
sports person i don't like teamwork no
really i saw that without that but uh
yeah the framing of this thing is like
we gotta do put the green this green
guys is because uh yeah well i like the
green i think it's a good contrast it
looks nice it does look nice but uh you
know i've always liked just doing things
myself and so i've always picked things
that i could do on my own and just do by
myself i love that stuff do not forget
no i love doing things on my on my own
terms uh the way i want to do them and
i've always just been like that wow yeah
so for me it was like you know making
youtube videos or working as a real
estate agent on my you know on my own
projects or uh you know high schools
working uh well not really working but
uh like playing music i could do that on
my own wow are you not worried that god
forbid there's an accident or are you
becoming
incapacitated or whatever that word is
and you just cannot
generate revenue anymore that's why i
save
so yeah i save everything so like i've
always planned for a point where if it
stops the next day it'd be okay what if
you
uh what if you die everything you've
built dies
there's no legacy or longevity well i
think the videos would live on so i
would be at this point knocking what if
anything would happen i'd i'd be so
happy the videos are out there
okay so your your legacy you'd say is in
the youtube videos i would say so now if
youtube introduces shorts and you have
not done any shorts i'm starting to do
shorts
starting that i'm starting to do that
got it but you knew that's a five year
lifetime so after you after you die
everything you've built for 50 years i
think jack would carry it on jack would
carry on the iced coffee hour got it i
hope he wouldn't change with graham and
jeff you know
graham alex and jack
jack crossover alex
that's interesting yeah jack would
probably carry it on uh and then i don't
know you know with the money take care
of take care of take care of his people
employees
wow that's just dedicated employees yeah
you know one thing i respect about
people is people who know who they are
and what they want that's very much
graham right yeah it's just you know
what you want
and there's no argument there
and i know what i want and it's that
uh and both are equally right you know i
i get stressed out easily so for me a
thousand people or more than like more
than alex and jack for me is like too
much to think about i can't think about
anything wow my brain space is a hundred
percent so like anything else like
that's why you're saying like uh you're
you're into jack i don't remember it
it's just my brain can't retain
more than the most essential information
to get through the next like week that's
that's it wow yeah if i don't need to
retain it it's not there
it's it's bad your description of gram
is one of the most accurate descriptions
and this is what i tell people too
graham knows exactly what he wants and
he does exactly what he wants he only
does what he wants fortunately
what graham wants does not hurt anyone
and it's
thankfully yeah i didn't think of it
that way yeah not the next hitler okay
yeah i wanted to be a positive yeah
nothing i do would ever would ever be
graham never does things that he does
not want to do
never
wow yeah
does it make it difficult to work with
him yes
okay so let's dissect this guy
like it's it's very good for the
business because generally speaking
graham knows what's good he is a pretty
good i do what's good for the business
yeah
the found founders are notoriously
difficult to work with
essentially your founder of a channel
photo whatever it's they're they're
impossible to work with and we just have
to suck it up and
yeah fortunately graham and i have very
similar ideals on most things yes so
graham is a very much like my way or the
highway type person yeah but generally
speaking i will agree with the decisions
that he makes so it makes it easier on
us and jack
jack will throw out an idea to me
immediately i'll shut it down and then
he'll bring it up consistently and i'll
start thinking i start marinating on the
api and usually after about a month or
two i'll be like you know what we'll try
it how's that like i'm instead of i'm
i'm 100 against it i'm i'm now like 50
50. let's try it nice so there's some
things to jackle through out there that
uh just take me a little bit that's all
that's cool yeah yeah the way i think
about it is um
i mean you know both all of us want the
same thing we want to live comfortably
we want to have a legacy and we want to
do good for the world i think the way i
think about it is
once i finish my thousand videos
i i realize that if i die the channel
dies
and if the channel dies then everything
we're working towards is meaningless so
for me is is my dream is to build a
100-year company
how do you build a 100-year company when
you're gonna die in 50 years you know
there's no other option but to hire
people
so the goal is to hire as many people as
possible to build the institution of nas
daily the institution of nas
that that impact
is so sexy
like
imagine bringing a thousand people to
work together to work on something that
is important a thousand people at the
same time like it will be a thou it will
not it will be 10 000 times more
impactful
than one person doing it you know
because there's scale yes that's what i
want to build
so uh we're 120 people now and i'm
motivated by the size of the company as
opposed to the revenue of the company
wow so you're going to 10x your
employees basically
yeah we're going to be 250 by the end of
this year and i hope to be a thousand in
five years that's hiring one person
every three days
yeah
possible oh gosh what are they what do
they all do i'm like i don't know
i'm like what do a thousand people do
that
250 couldn't accomplish right now
so you know with nas academy you know we
it's one it's operationally intensive
but two we're building exciting
technology right we have 20 engineers
because you know we're building a
different way to learn we're building
not just video files and give me money
it's like cohort based learning we're
building different ways to discover
courses we're building different
curriculum we're building nft classes
crypto classes engineering classes
whatever it is
and
um you know
curriculum team is three people
operations team is 20 people uh
engineering 20 people a product three
people uh you know marketing six people
hr four people you know
there's video editors we have like 20
video editors because we're making
courses we're making nice daily videos
we're making you know there's there's 20
channels that we're responsible for in
13 different languages so that we upload
100 pieces of content every week
can you upload 100 pieces of content by
yourself every week
that's why you need a team well unless
we do clips we could clip everything i'm
sure we could find we still would need
more people if you wanted to do that you
still yeah but i think that's true i
think there's a point where there's
diminishing returns first video you post
100 second video
90 but you have to appeal to different
audiences yes which is how you can
continue to not like burn out your
audience exactly 100 videos is that like
different languages too or like yeah so
we have 13 channel 13 languages on five
different platforms yeah snapchat tick
tock instagram facebook youtube
and then arabic hebrew spanish bahasa
wow uh so every video we make on nasa
every course we put on academy every
video put on us daily we've built
software
to take it and put subtitles in a
different language
and i'll tell you a story when i hit 10
million followers on facebook i was
celebrating i was so happy
i was celebrating with my friends and
then i realized
oh my god my dad is not one of my
followers like i found 10 million people
and my dad and my mom are not one of
them because they don't understand the
videos because it's in english
if you speak me they speak arabic if you
speak english you're talking to the
minority 20 of the world speaks english
80 does not [ __ ] know what we're
talking about
that's crazy alex does your does do your
extended family do they speak english
uh barely
they don't know what the hell you're
doing here they think you're wasting
your life away they they actually don't
know what i do because they don't
understand youtube yeah and english
uh
yep so when we started putting subtitles
in arabic and made a whole new channel
called nas daily arabic
it got five million followers
one percent of the arab world follows
nice daily two percent of
vietnam follows nas daily and i don't
speak a single word of vietnamese
that's powerful
so
we think that everything you're making
all your content that you guys are
making is like you know you're literally
saving lives financial lives with your
content
but you're actually
you're only like making the rich richer
if somebody's on youtube speaking
english in america i mean they're the
richest in the world
can someone in mexico or in vietnam
benefit from your financial advice
it's your responsibility to make that
content for them in their language i'm
worried though because people ask me to
make content for like could you make
content centered around the uk or like
different countries it's so different
that a lot of the just do a roth ira
index funds doesn't apply in a lot of
places yeah so my advice is very us
focused and it has to because that's
that's the only market i know
makes sense but
money is universal crypto at some point
is universal i think the cryptocurrency
audience would be worldwide yes yeah
localize it
by the way so he was mentioning this to
me last night i was curious about the
crypto content and i looked it up
apparently ten percent of my audience
comes from india for cryptocurrency
which is wow which is way higher than
almost every other topic so i make video
about stocks it's like ninety percent
u.s
crypto 10 india that's less um
yeah
so and australia was another big one
i told you this yesterday graham you are
a 10 million follower channel
but because of the process now you only
have 3 million
but
what the people that everything your
content everything 10 million people
need to follow you
and how do you suggest doing that
different languages okay so multiple
ways one is shorts yes start creating
shorts two is start creating universal
content which is forget the roth ira for
a little bit and make a show called
universal finance or a show called
crypto
and and literally just make crypto
content once a week as a new show and
turn it into shorts and you'll just get
a lot of people interested so now your
content became universal and then after
that step two is start localizing it you
know build youtube channels or facebook
channels or for youtube channels in
spanish and then in arabic and then in
yada yada yada then go on wherever
humans go so tick tock snapchat facebook
youtube
instagram every content has to be
multiplied 90 times
on these different channels in different
languages um
and when you do that
you'll get to 10 million
oh man that's graham just sees he hears
that and he's like too much work too
much okay yeah i'm i'm like like a
sniper where like you get one thing to
do and i'll do that really well for me
that was the main channel uh and then
everything else is kind of similar to
that so like i could sniper that one
little thing but yeah you lost me
no it makes sense yeah
i mean i'm happy to hear that because it
shows i have an opportunity here yes you
have a i would recommend you do that
because because i could see the light in
your eyes when you explain this like
you've got it mapped out like that's
something that you could do a hundred
percent yeah and you've already got the
reach on that so you could take it from
50 million to 100 million now yeah yeah
great please follow
nas finance in arabic
and spanish
and every other language
whatever you speak
uh he's got you covered
yeah
basically
so i want to know what drives you what
motivates you to do so much to build
such a massive team and and continue
pushing when it seems like you've
basically already made it
already made it wow interesting
so
where did you guys grow up here
in vegas no no i didn't know you did not
grow up in vegas i mean here is in the
us like we grew up yeah we like i mean
southern california
so i grew up in the most complicated
conflict in the world
the israel-palestinian conflict the most
complicated never-ending solution 15 or
10 u.s presidents tried to fix this
conflict couldn't
you guys introduced health care you
couldn't fix israel and palestine
so i grew up in that area as a
palestinian israeli so whatever
motivates me has to do with my childhood
right has to do with how i grew up if
you grow up seeing people die for a
piece of land it puts a bit in your
brain if you grow up seeing people kill
each other for religion it kind of [ __ ]
you up if you grow up seeing so much
hatred rockets falling on people killing
them
attacks terrorist attacks uh uh
all that [ __ ]
it makes you think what is important in
life
is it making money well you could be a
billionaire people are still gonna die
in your neighborhood
um
it's actually the most important thing
in life is just
doing something that could potentially
save a life
and for me i think it's politics it's
not dentistry it's not medicine
i think eventually politics is the most
important field that everybody needs to
be in so how do you get into the
politics world well one you need a lot
of followers you need to be really good
in front of the camera
so we're trying to do that and two you
need a lot of money so you need to be
independent so you need 100 million
followers and 100 million dollars
if you really want to affect change in
this world and stop people from dying
that's my goal that's what motivates me
get 100 million dollars get 100 million
followers and then use those two things
to fix the unfixable to fix
these conflicts around the world would
you do that where would you start
when you grew up yeah yeah yeah i i
think
you know a lot of people [ __ ] on like
governments governments in effect
especially in america there's a lot of
hatred against governments right oh
cannot do things politicians are all
corrupt
you know at the end of the day guys the
only reason you're alive is because a
politician decided not to bomb the crap
out of you
that's what it boils down to politics is
the most important thing on the planet
uh so my 20-year goal is i want to be in
the private sector for the next 10 15
years
and eventually i want to move on to the
public sector because for me that's
where the real meaning is
uh and then i'll just have no more
meaning left in like in like you know
making money or whatever yeah yeah
yeah so after that what will you feel
what if you solve that conflict no you
could not solve that yeah
and there's always and there's always
going to be a conflict yeah always going
to be something you solve one and
another will pop up so if that another
will pop up but exactly probably make it
you know net positive still exactly yeah
it's a lifelong mission yeah i we were
saying this to kevin right before he ran
for governor on the podcast by the way
kevin white
kevin
me too oh yeah the guy the california
governor right california yeah you were
supporting him pretty a lot yeah yeah
and we mentioned it now i don't want to
take a hundred percent credit but uh i
mentioned to him i'm like listen with
with the following that you have and his
ability to speak he has he had a chance
to run yes and what happened and uh well
you know he i would say he got way
closer than a lot of people thought and
did quite well he got like six hundred
thousand seven hundred thousand votes
what in california on the recall which
is insane for for a like you know a
youtuber 700 000 people but i but i was
explaining to the reach that you have on
social media and i wouldn't be surprised
if at some point social media people get
into politics because of their reach yes
they have a reach that just advertising
dollars can't get to yes and so
you know it like if if you know elon
musk runs yeah he'd get a huge vote just
because of his reach already
or a mark cuban or a mr beast runs at
some point like everyone who grew up
with mr beast would would just
inevitably vote for him almost everybody
basically yeah um we've already have the
influencer president who was president
trump yeah he is the first influencer
president basically it's possible so i
think it's gonna happen i think it's
only a matter of time because everyone
growing up watching people
uh it's gonna go in that direction the
current the current prime minister the
next prime minister of israel is is is
scheduled to be uh a tv personality
which is basically a creator right so
everybody grew up watching him on tv and
now he went to baltics and now he's the
prime minister so i'm curious who are
the favorite people that you've met or
the most interesting
the most interesting people that i've
met
you guys wow
you know
the the world is full of uh
i mean dude this there's some crazy
interesting and there's some crazy
inspiring right something interesting is
like some guy looks like tarzan and he
lives in hong kong right he literally
looks like tarzan and he lives in the
jungle we gotta see it i gotta see this
you gotta see this
just type on youtube he is the real
tarzan oh my gosh you weren't kidding i
wasn't joking look at that
holy cow wow
how did you find this guy
oh my god i had a meet-up in hong kong
and someone said my friend lives in the
jungle and looks like tarzan and works
at disney you want to make a video about
him
like yeah
and so we went visiting him that video
you know how many views it got 100
million views oh my god 100 million
views how did this guy's life change
after that video he became popular
overnight in hong kong you know people
start taking pictures with him and
everything and um
you know i think the beauty of making
videos is that both parties benefit
we benefited because we get more
followers
he benefited because his story now is
out to the world so it's a great pareto
efficiency it's a win-win
the other interesting inspiring people i
would say is the youngest billionaire in
the world
well the youngest billionaire in the
world is not kylie jenner
it is a guy in india
named ritesh
and he started
oh you know oyo hotel yeah yeah the
founder of oyo hotel yeah uh you know
there's like thousands of oyo hotels in
india and around the world
and you know he's 26 year 27 now and
he's about to ipo his company
for like i don't know god knows i made
10 billion dollars
i mean that's nuts yeah
that's inspiring right so that's another
person uh
um
especially because he grew up in like
like like a village where people have
100 bucks a month
so it's it's it's amazing to see uh
entrepreneurship enable you to become a
billionaire if you work hard enough um
who else is interesting
you know there's there's a crazy people
the guy who wins like the mustache the
most beautiful mustache in the world
like really huge take uh take some notes
from this guy jack
yeah
um
yeah you know that's that's kind of what
we
find
that's cool who is your favorite who's
the most memorable to you
i think uh
i i you don't have a favorite child and
therefore every every video is a child
so what's the first one that comes to
mind like you're the most memorable just
whatever's the first
doesn't even have to be a good
performing video
um
[Music]
it wasn't about a person my favorite
video is called jews versus arabs
and it's about uh
you know i was uh i was sitting making a
video in jerusalem and then some girl
comes to me and says you're palestinian
you're arab get out of here so it's kind
of like a racist interaction
and
uh that was the most meaningful video
i've done in my life because
it was shot on camera because my camera
was on yeah and so the interaction
between me and a 15 year old kid
she hates me
my people hate her
and it's just it's really interesting to
see how the pumpkin she's 15. oh my gosh
and you have that interaction on camera
yeah what was the ending of that what
happened
she left
she said get out of here or you
shouldn't be proud to be arab or you
guys kill us and it's understandable why
you would hate an arab okay it's very
easy to hate arabs my people
i also hate some of them it's very easy
to hit us so i understand why she would
hate us because you know you kill us you
bomb us we cannot be safe around you
and another hand is like okay not every
arab is a terrorist and then you know
her uncle who was there who was also
racist
uh he he took her away wow
and they both left
jeez
how many of these do you film and then
just decide afterwards you're not gonna
post it
this video took me two months to think
about and post because it's very
sensitive and it's not i don't want to
be known
as the guy who had a racist interaction
yes
so i kind of want to be known for just
like only good things but it's just it's
difficult and there's so much
it's so difficult um
with nice daily every video takes 24
hours so you make it on the day it
uploads the next day so there's no time
to think
only with that video i waited two months
but everything else yeah make it today
upload tomorrow has there been any
videos that you posted that have led to
some backlash
always yeah there's always backlash i
if you are you know if before making
content right if you have 10 friends
you probably have one enemy
right let's say one guy you don't like
he doesn't like you
but you have nine friends life is good
but if you multiply that by a million
you have 10 million friends
and now you have one million enemies
so nas daily has roughly five million
enemies five ten maybe ten million
enemies around the world
that sucks so every video we make has
backlash
some sort of backlash i don't like the
way you're dressed i don't like the way
you talk
i don't like your mustache
i don't like this i'm like that so
when you get big enough
it's inevitable i'm sure you get that
too i'm sure you guys get that as well
right a little bit not much it's weird
on youtube
i want to say 99.9 percent super
friendly yes it's then when it when
someone reposts something to like
facebook or twitter or like another
platform where people don't know me then
the comments are wild what do they say
what's the number one reason people hate
you comfortable
no bunch of old faces that's my punch
it's my punch
no we always joke because that doesn't
it's like the the most phrased word on
youtube like the phrase on youtube is
like you have a very punchable feeling
like everyone has a punch
what are what's the other reasons yeah
cheap
you're cheap yes are you cheap yes yes
yeah but i think it doesn't look like i
think it's endearing i don't know i i
don't i don't mind it
we have to beg you for this set just so
you know yeah i was paying for hack
no
jack owns half of the channel so okay so
you get half of ad revenue yeah okay
it's fair yeah but still i mean this
this set is only a recent development
and beforehand we were doing it on a
couch microphones we got for free
yes yeah
using light uh towels as light diffusers
still wow yeah so we got like actual
studio lights and a nice sound i agree
this set has made a difference and i
remember we built that made a lot of
money because of this yeah i agree the
set was a good choice i like the couch
and people initially liked the couch
because they said like
those comments said i missed the couch
because it felt like a very laid back
just you know buddies on the couch just
chatting and i get that i get it but
this but i think also they were used to
the other one so any change would have
been bad true so
i'm happy with this how much do you
spend per month
uh
not much well the thing is i'm paying
two mortgages so like that skews things
heavily
um
well i mean the keeping two more
mortgages don't get the mortgage you're
paying in your own assets yeah um
i got four thousand five thousand four
thousand dollars a month what do you
spend it
on yeah
yeah that's that seems like a lot more i
mean i don't know if you don't count
like the occasional needing something
for like your business or something yeah
so so i'm yeah okay so if we're taking
out business related expenses a lot of
that's discretionary in the sense like
we don't need it but if it could help us
you know do that hard drive yes
business stuff like that what about like
labor costs
uh
basically asking about both their
salaries yeah well jack's basically on a
percentage so whatever the podcast does
um
so it's dependent on the performance
so i don't really count the labor the
real only labor costs that i have for
you would be 22 of the second channel
and 30 of the mentorship i'm thinking
like i don't know it's probably three to
four thousand dollars a month like
personal expenses because that would
include maybe like you know the car
insurance
well that's not that much it's it's not
it's not a lot of money i would say it's
probably close to about two thousand
dollars that grand spending per month
you have health care you have car
insurance you have food that's a
rounding error that you're spending per
month
probably yeah wow yeah because i don't
need i don't need the the most expensive
things are the two mortgages
and that's it but that's a profitable
thing right if you rent it out yes i
could rent it out but if we actually
count like interest property taxes stuff
like this
i don't know that's that's maybe three
thousand a month wow like it's not much
but i
i enjoy that and then everything else is
is discretionary for
it's usually if i'm spending money on
something it's something that i know i
could get a return on or it's something
that will keep its value if the car is
something the car was like 300 grand but
i knew that would make more money 300
grand yeah what did you have the ford gt
you have the ford gt that's 300 grand
yeah but now it's almost 400 grand so
but i bought this car knowing that a
single function device yes this car to
me was something that i could buy and
it's it worst case it's a savings
account so i'd rather keep my money in a
car than sitting in ally bank so between
the two the car is already better but i
knew the car was going to be going up in
value
it's just it's such a collectible item
so i knew worst case it's going to be
like five five percent a year
so i'd rather have the car
so like certain things like that i could
justify because i know it's gonna make
money yes close to a hundred thousand
dollars in watches
yeah those make money
they're it's better to have your money
in a watch in in the right watch at the
right price than a savings account
and i believe that's in the right
qualification in the right watch it's
also better to have it in nfd
than in cash some could say some could
say someone could say they're right and
if it's in the right energy yeah yeah
but watches they're they're they can be
a fantastic investment so like stuff
like that i i really enjoy that but i'd
like uh the collectible nature of being
able to buy something and have it be
worth more than you think you could be a
part of you're gonna hate me for this do
you know how much i have in cash
that's sitting there eroding away
probably uh one and a half million two
million dollars three to four million
dollars sitting there in cash yeah but
that's part of the business though right
or is that no
you personally this is me personally
like two million why don't you invest it
that's
that's terrible i don't know how i don't
know you're here at the iced coffee hour
like i don't know how to invest
i know how it's just it bores the crap
out of me you gotta get somebody to do
it for you is even is money in a bank
account more exciting
no it's just not exciting all of money
is not if you could pay someone right
now
thousand dollars to just set it up for
you and put move the money from a bank
account into an index fund would you do
that absolutely i got you man i got you
right now
i'm telling you i could set it up in 15
minutes if you're american i don't want
to do anything with your with america
the tax system here is crazy i don't pay
taxes
can you not invest in a us-based index
fund no i don't want to i don't want to
don't want it no i can invest i can
invest from singapore so there's no
capital gains in singapore right and
there's no income tax in dubai you do
not want to invest in anything in the
u.s market no no i i want i will invest
from my singapore bank yes yeah i will
not tax taxing that okay
all you need to do is a total stock
market index fund you could go so
expensive now
it's
it i mean
more expensive is it being too expensive
right now especially if you're talking
about index funds everything is
overpriced
that's what they were saying a year ago
and for the last 10 years yeah
last year
i was busy making videos
and what about the year before that oh
it was busy you're making videos and you
say you wanted the year before that i
had no money you say you want to get to
100 million dollars i think
realistically one of the best
contributors to getting to 100 million
is going to be investing 200
i i'm indexing on like one stock to
appreciate which is the nas academy
stock right so that's why i'm spending
25
hours every day on that stock but if you
have that much money in your own
personal account that's separate from
the business yes you've got to invest
that money at least invest half yes
two million in cash two million invested
and forget that the two million you
invest forget that ever even exist just
basically burn it to the ground doesn't
exist anymore don't look at it for 20
years yeah that's that's your fallback
in case anything happens that that two
is going to grow to five
yeah it's true that's what you need to
do and just a total stock market index
fund that's it just that one thing and
you could even do 80 total stock market
index 20 emerging markets are
international
that way you get more exposure to
other countries outside the u.s it would
take you 30 minutes to set it oh yeah
easily 30 minutes i i gotta do it it's
just
i've dreamed of being rich but the
minute i became rich i realized how
how
useless it is i'm not useless it's very
useful how
boring
it is to be rich
do you feel that way or no you don't
like
it's
it's it's it's a number on a screen like
you work like a donkey and i'm working
like a donkey to increase that number on
a screen
in which you only use 0.01 of it every
month for nothing
i mean
i don't well because it's sitting in a
savings account doing nothing you know
if you if you
did something with it you would start to
see the benefit like if you knew that
you'd have an extra 100 000 a year
let's just say let's even say on two
million dollars let's say you would have
sixty thousand dollars a year
extra just here it is in your account do
whatever you want with it spend all of
it and it's going to come back to you
you would be able to make such a big
difference for things that are important
to you yeah right next was 60 000 for 30
minutes of work
so even if the money is like boring to
you
i guarantee you'll find a great way to
spend at 60 000 in a way that's
meaningful for you okay okay i'm
convinced all right cool i will do it do
my job
i will do it yeah no i mean i i i will
do it i i think it's
there is there's
you know it's kind of like uh what do
you call it i like by the way i've
traveled for four years and i don't have
an airline miles accounts
like i i for four years every one week i
was on a plane and i just don't have uh
a mile that's another problem that's not
as nearly as big of a problem as the
cash yeah pretty small cash is way
bigger yeah yeah
but you should have been paying with a
good credit card getting the points
getting the miles
i would say that's 50 off it would be a
good idea for you to hire just a
personal like investor someone's just
called a private bank well
like one an actual employee that would
just make these decisions well that
person needs to be making 10k a month
for it to be worth their time no no it's
so easy so easy if there's something you
cannot get someone who's like you know
how it would probably take them 10 hours
a week to do everything that they needed
for you
the problem is that if you get somebody
licensed there are so many regulations
for a licensed person to do investment
advice that they would have to charge
some yeah extreme amount and they
wouldn't probably be on their own but
you could be one of multiple of their
like clients yeah but it's like
but if you get somebody who's just a
personal finance enthusiast who's like
hey you know if i were to do this you
know i would probably just do this yeah
if it were me they sign you up for the
credit cards they give you everything
that you need and all you need to do is
either swipe or just keep your bank
account higher i don't know the
regulations for that it's so strict on
like
paying somebody else to do your finances
it's just regulations
you're supposed to that's why you know
oh you're not supposed to pay something
right but you're supposed to be licensed
you're supposed to be licensed yeah like
if you're like graham i'm gonna pay you
ten thousand dollars to invest you can't
do that oh gosh no that would be like
the biggest violation i would never do
that really yeah what if i give you a
hundred thousand
no i'm kidding
deal
no no every law has a price yeah
interesting yeah yeah no i think one of
the one of the issues that nas daily has
faced is that we have no country you
know when we let when i left america i
went to singapore now i'm getting out of
singapore to go to dubai and it's just
only in the last year have i had a real
country presence but for you is much
easier i'm in america i'm an american
i'm with uncle sam for the rest of my
life
right so i got to get better with this
system but for me i spent three years
figuring out what is a better system
than uncle sam that saves me more money
and i think i found it finally in two
countries and so now i'm trying to
establish financial ties in those
countries singapore in dubai okay no
capital gains in singapore and no
capital gains in dubai and no income tax
isn't to buy slightly better because the
no income tax
it it is it is but so that the way i'm
structuring this this is not financial
advice uh is all my stock holdings are
in singapore and all my you know all my
income because i'm a resident i'm a
resident of dubai
so
this way you get the best of both worlds
singapore is much
easier to invest in from venture capital
funds because they've done it before a
lot of companies have listed in the
nasdaq from singapore dubai is still
very fresh
you know dubai have capital gains tax no
none so why not just do everything to
buy
for investors i think they're slightly
more comfortable investing in a
singapore company
than a dubai company for now but i think
that'll change in the future got it and
how does dubai get away with
no tax where do they get their money
from i was looking at the government's
uh uh uh income statement actually like
uh like a week ago i think five people
think dubai is oil money but only five
percent of the revenue of the government
of dubai comes from oil five percent
sixty percent come from fees it says
fees i don't know what fees registration
fees
uh uh uh you know there are taxes for
like banks and oil companies and some
sectors
uh you know there's maybe like import
tax maybe or like maybe like the airport
i don't know but it says 60 comes from
fees
and then there's a v80
fees
no one's gonna question that yeah
another one is thirty percent vt which
is five percent yeah on on like sales
these i'm wondering if it's like import
fees like if you take a could be into
dubai
you're paying an extra fee it probably
is that
and that pays for everything it was
crazy doesn't dubai have like the
bugatti police cars is that is that
dubai oh yeah the audi r8 do they have
that yeah like that is every police car
in audi r8 no it's like five
out of 500. okay do you see them ever or
i saw one or two i saw bmw why why did
they do that like what's the point of
publicity like i was under the
impression all of them were out really
yeah well that's the impression they
want you to have yeah
the idea i think
so i think dubai is like
the realizes the importance of media
which just like hollywood like you know
hollywood is like the best propaganda
army arm for the us ever existed
you know i was a village kid in israel
watching
uh uh pursuit of happiness and i was
crying i was like i love america it's so
amazing you know american dream
oh independence day oh my god you know
like every
every country has its own form of
propaganda propaganda is not a bad thing
there's a bad north korean propaganda
there is good hollywood propaganda and i
think you know for dubai they're
building their own image right for on
social media not on the big screen on
social media and so if you want to get
more views on social media do something
extreme build the tallest tower in the
world get five
bugatti and it works
because they need to change the image
because your image and other people's
images of dubai is like it's a desert
or it is uh it is a bunch of you know uh
terrorists because it's arabs
and it's like no like it's it's actually
a different image completely if you
visit and see i think i think the
wealthy image where you see like the
islands the tallest building and the r8
you know police cars and the lines of
like rolls-royces everywhere
i got a couple rapid fire questions
yeah
what's your overhead
oh good one uh nice daily 170k a month
nasa academy
500 came on so you're netting 350 a
month well what is it i just did it yeah
nas academy is not profitable yet okay
not as daily as profitable the nascar is
not profitable why
it's definitely different legal entities
oh so so the engineers and the tech and
so still working as a startup trying to
get yeah that's kind of his venture back
got it so we raised 11 million dollars
and we use that to to build
yeah 11 million that's a lot of money to
build
is that a lot of money yeah really
no it's not to me that seems like a lot
i'm thinking like oh you know making a
teachable account
you know 99 bucks a month make the
content you're making what is
effectively like a skill share right
you're making what is similar to a skill
show right we're making
basically the closest one is monthly
okay you know monthly no
[Music]
no it's kind of like a
a better a better version of skillshare
and udemy
something along the lines a better
version of skillshare yes okay just call
it that but actually we're building
creator tools so like we're building
creator tech so you are a creator you
are a creator like localization
gram stuff in arabic we have a google
translate for video so if you want to
make your videos into arabic we can spin
around in 10 minutes make all your
channel in arabic that's tech we're
building uh education tech you know all
that stuff costs money got it okay we
also look so we raised 11 million
and we have we have like 7 million left
in the bank
um but we're losing money every month
but you know the goal is in the next
three four months to go and raise series
b you know go raise 40 50 million
dollars and build even more
you know that that is the game i want to
play yeah
and uh for that you need to hire yeah
i'm so different from that it's it's
weird i wouldn't do something unless it
immediately makes money from day one
somebody told me this before a venture
capitalist told me this before if you
want if you like profit
today
it means you care about today more than
you care about tomorrow
like you're actually pessimistic about
the future
basically what it boils down to if you
invest today it means you think tomorrow
is going to be so much better that it's
worth losing money today
and when i heard that i was like yeah
why am i making like 400k profit per
month [ __ ] that
so i literally took took the 400k and i
hired 50 more people to me to me it's
about sustainability because if you know
you can make money today you know you
can make money tomorrow yeah and so at
that point the money today is something
that you could reinvest even more and
then let it grow but it's but it's
making money today yeah but
but the money but you said reinvest
right yes but what if you can reinvent
beyond the dollar that you have
what if you can invest your dollar but
then i worry dollars
i'm worried about growth too quickly
about getting you know putting what do
they call putting the cart before the
horse bro what is growth too quickly
nfts go from zero dollars so it's a
hundred million dollars in like a year
there's no and if anything we are doing
growth too slow
i don't know i think slow and steady
slowest
yeah i've always taken a different
approach though i've always
done that i mean most likely in 20 years
we'll end up in the same spot
right it's just i mine is a lot more
like this
maybe i might yeah i don't know yeah
you know i yeah the way i feel about it
is like you know i'm 39
you know i have like this much left i'll
never be poor you'll never be poor
you'll never be poor
it's like let's let's take a couple of
risks yeah
what is the last time you took a big
risk
did you ever bet your existence i'm
betting my existence on this no he
definitely is not you should bet your
existence on something
i don't want to take unnecessary risk
it's not necessary because if you bet it
you end up with something amazing
no
no
to me that's unnecessary risk like elon
musk bet his existence on spacex
yeah no i don't think i could do that
though
makes sense how about you jack could i
bet my existence meaning everything that
i've worked for everything that i have
yeah just put it in one big thing
if i was extremely sure of it i probably
would but for me to find something that
i'm so sure of that i would bet
everything i've worked towards probably
not you wouldn't find i i i think it
could happen but it's probably pretty
unlikely let me give you an example i
was so sure about youtube and i i've
wanted to make youtube videos when i was
21 years old and i just i felt it and i
was like i i just felt like this is
something i have to do
i i didn't do it for five years i was 26
when i made my first youtube video and i
was working as a real estate agent i was
even making up to a million dollars a
year on youtube i was still working as a
real estate agent i couldn't knock that
off because i knew that it was so risky
and i waited until the point where i was
like
now is the right choice wow that took me
three years to get to that point kind of
like mark robert right mark robert was
had 10 million followers and he was
working yeah he was working nasa yeah
right so to me that was like i
you never want to bet everything on one
thing in case it doesn't work out i
wanted something to fall back on it for
me you know it it as long
if if i scale back on working as a real
estate agent
to any degree it's so much more
difficult to build that client base back
up if i've spent like eight years
building up a client base it's
consistent if i start turning that away
then when it's at its peak that could be
disastrous in the event something else
doesn't work out but don't you trust
your inner self like if i could do it
once i could do it again
i'll tell you something right yeah yeah
right now you have proven that the
masses like your personality even though
some people say punchable face
you've proven you have a product market
fit and i've proven that despite the
haters i have enough people that like me
yeah for me
therefore i could do whatever the hell i
want i can come back and just start from
zero and build nice data again i don't
have the energy the same energy as it
did when i was 21. well how do you know
uh 31. got yeah if it's an energy thing
i i i i see that especially if you have
kids and a family oh my god yeah yeah i
know i look back at uh like everything
really the last 10 years i'm like those
are these are crazy hours i mean maybe i
could do it again
but uh like today i just i probably have
eighty-five percent of the energy i had
back then maybe eighty percent you're
eighty percent what are you at now what
i used to have back then yeah still a
hundred
no i would say no i'd say a year ago
today i'd say you went from 100 to i
think 100 to 82. oh my god he's saying
you're decreasing in performance no i
think i'm increasing increasing output
jack is increasing output decreasing
time the hustle okay so if we're talking
about direct work hustle sure i hustle
less now but i'm not opposed to going
back and if i have to hustle
i'm not opposed to that if i have to do
it i have to do it you have anything
tying you down yes like you have a
family of kids nothing
he's hiking today
like tying me down insofar as like i
want to travel and i want to go
experience stuff seriously yeah i wanted
to do a spa day with jack and alex today
and jack was like no i can't i i got
hiking things going hiking you're tied
down by hiking yes you're gonna go walk
on a mountain
that sounds amazing like here that's we
have different preferences
the point is it's like i i do have the
grind i do have the hustle but i love to
spend that efforts doing other things
that like i feel like are more rewarding
and valuable for me like going hiking
with my housemates like going out last
night i've lived in las vegas for
like nearly a year now and i've gone out
to the strip maybe like three times so
that was the third time
that i've gone out yeah that was the
first time no we've gone to the wind
before no but we never like went like
okay sure but that's also on your like
because if we go out with graham it's
generally always it's it's on his terms
so it's like we go to this hotel we go
to this casino we do this he needs to be
independent bro this was this was like
probably the third time i've actually
gone out i've never been to a club ever
so i'm trying to spend now some time i
like jack to like go in china right
clubs are overrated
how are you 23. oh okay well there's
also that okay but yeah i mean
i i like i i still have the hustle but i
want to spend that efforts and stuff
doing stuff that i find more fulfilling
like i love work it's great and it's
rewarding but i think i need to spare
some time for other things that i think
are more fulfilling and
are closer to my end goal
what percentage of your life guys do you
spend working
oh probably 85 90 for me 90.
yeah you go to the spot today how's that
90 uh it's work uh where's the workbench
the family we're doing i wanted to do a
whole spa day we got a sponsor in this
to family and i forget who meant juices
you mentioned yeah
he would be fun to do a spot at all of
us because jack has never gotten a
massage before it's just for content for
content but i think it's graham and i
have different ideas of what work is so
for example you ask me jack what do you
spend like what percentage of your time
you spend like working i would probably
say like 40
wow yeah but realistically as graham
deep inhale exhale but as far as as far
as me doing stuff that i'm not
necessarily enjoying but i have to get
it done because it's like a requirement
of living you know what i mean probably
closer to like 75 percent got it yeah
that makes sense 80 for example like
setting up my
back door roth array setting up like
different things fixing stuff at the
house like i'm always busy last night it
was also work basically i see i don't
qualify that as well that is working
you're not working
something beautiful could come out look
what happened we went to the dinner we
got this content and you're going to
make 2k from ad revenue that's work
let's hope we make 2k then they'll be
good that'd be nice yeah you gotta make
two let's see yeah
that's cool yeah i think i'm more like
you than like 85 to 90 yeah but i love
work yeah like if you give me a day to
do whatever i wanted i would work i
don't think you do graham
i don't think you love work i do nope i
disagree
i think graham thinks he loves work
because it's good enough i think graham
has been on one of the longest and
gnarliest dopamine detoxes of anyone i
know
i think jack has a skewed perspective
because i only tell jack about the times
where i am just like having a difficult
time when i reach out to jack hey man i
can't think of a topic today what do you
think yeah nothing going on that's all
jack hears jack never hears the times
where he doesn't hear from why don't you
share the good stuff with him hey jack
look at this amazing this video is true
it's like our relationship is built off
of jack this happened man can you fix
this this is terrible and i'm like oh
man he really seems stressed out that is
true but the thing is to let yourself
get to the point where you are stressed
out and you're you're like antsy and
kind of frantic and sometimes like you
know
nervous or irritable to let yourself get
to that point there has to be something
in your life that is not going so well
it's like i i don't necessarily i would
say it's normal it is normal to feel
those things but you also feel them in
higher volume than other people do and
also i think like
if you're content with your life and
you're fulfilled and you're happy you
don't let yourself
like unreasonably feel anger or or bad
emotions like that like at the end of
the day if something bad happens you
know you'll be okay because every every
other like aspect of your life is is
balanced and content no i don't believe
that yeah i feel like if you're nervous
you care yeah you know shawn mendes had
a documentary with casey neistat i don't
even see he said if you're nervous it
means you care if you're not nervous you
don't give up i think being yeah i agree
feeling nervous but feeling nervous in a
good way because you're versus feeling
nervous in a bad way so those are two
different i remember reading somewhere
that you don't feel emotion or you don't
get angry or upset or sad or happy about
things that you uh that you don't care
about yes so you only feel those
emotions towards things that you that
mean a lot to you correct and otherwise
if i didn't feel any emotion over the
channel i wouldn't care at all correct
would not be where it is today
the emotions good but i think it's i
think it's different because it's i'm
not talking about like things directly
tied to work but just in general like
being
sometimes irritable and stuff like that
outside of work and i think that because
of the stuff that you like your
work-life balance it tran it translates
into other things aspects of life that's
true but uh no i mean i i agree with
that i agree with that portion but uh
but yeah when you're working like eight
hours it's hard to come out of that it's
hard to you know snap and like when
you're so focused on one thing to then
like
emerge from this cocoon of the office
yeah
right but if you spent a little bit more
time like
introspecting and and thinking about
things and maybe i don't meditating i
don't meditate but just giving yourself
a little bit of time you know what i
mean and slowing down for a second i
think it would do you a lot of justice
yeah see this is the part where like
i'll disagree with jack for a few months
and then slowly over time he'll be
coming he'll wear me down a little bit
so this is one of those things where
like right i know i should be probably
meditating that's probably something i
should be doing i'm not doing it so you
should also do what he called vipassana
you know have you heard about vipassana
i i a lot of people are telling me to
meditate as well i'm also been opposed
to it for the last five years
uh but the pasta is basically you should
do like you should try it out it's like
a 10-day silence retreat
you just you go to this ashram in india
and you literally do not talk
for 10 days it kills you inside and
there's like 20 people around you and
there's a guru there and the whole line
and you cannot even write
like you cannot think you know internet
nothing you're just sitting there and
you've all know harari you know
universal harare the you know sapiens
the book
the book sapiens
okay
pretend we know nothing you're talking
to a brick wall just explain everything
no it's just the most popular book
that's sold in the last year
i didn't even know that recently if
there's anything
everybody if there's anything they told
us that was like 20 year old yeah
all right
if there's anything to get out of this
read the book sapiens because it'll
[ __ ] change your life
yeah including you guys it's like a
brief history of humankind anyway this
author who's super super rich super
popular super everything everybody loves
them uh he he's the busiest guy in the
world every day every year he goes 10
years 10 days the pasana
and just detox
and if he does it then you should do it
i should do it we should all do it i
would love to my housemate apple did it
i did it
yeah you did it oh that's cool it can't
work out it's literally just meditating
the entire time
that's cool yeah
i would like this might sound stupid
don't you get bored
probably for sure yeah people told me my
friend did it recently you start crying
because you want to speak you want to
express you start crying
graham doesn't do that yeah i don't mean
to like offend people who do that but to
me that sounds like a waste of time
i don't think people nowadays have
enough time
some could say this podcast is a waste
of time
i disagree it doesn't sound like a waste
of time but like what's what comes from
that like how do you how do you emerge
from that and you become deeper with who
you are i think that i think what's
happening is that because of technology
and the internet and friends and without
it's like your public persona and your
deep core persona are becoming so
different
and like there's graham on the internet
and there's graham in real life and i
think the whole idea of the puzzle is to
bring understand who you are and bring
it closer i think a lot of it's also
just having solitude because nowadays
nobody has solitude because you're
constantly being stimulated by like
conversation because you're always
texting people you get you know pinged
on your phone you're always being
stimulated by something but to remove
that stimulation finally gives you a
chance to just think and see what comes
to your brain and not to just reach for
your phone whenever you're bored or
something like that yeah jack i agree
with that but why do you need to go
not say anything for 10 days it just
doesn't click for me in my head probably
10 days is long enough for you to like
to break you like everyone could do a
day almost everyone could do two days
yes ten days that that takes a lot of
mental strength yeah that's what i think
i think the challenge is like a
challenge for yourself yeah you know
here's a suggestion to improve this this
podcast have a screen right here
so literally we could just go we're
passing up boom oh this how it looks
like amazing kind of like that's what
this is supposed to be oh really yeah
and we actually were planning that on
putting a screen right there but it's
behind our guests so we're still
thinking oh yeah this would be amazing
if i could just like google real quick
this is what it is yeah yeah
the tarzan this is how it looks like you
know
graham quick question for you yeah why
do you vlog it doesn't seem like it's
like
your type uh we're still trying to
figuring that out to be honest with you
initially i thought that it would be
like i'd want to do van life at some
point and i'd want to van life oh yeah
wait you get an event you go to around
the world i would love to be able to do
that there's a lot of followers for that
yeah and i think yeah so not only would
it be different content but i think we
could do something really unique with
the podcast kind of like what um jeff's
barber shop is doing with it with the
thing in the back we could take this on
the road yeah go around the us i think
doing that for like six months to a year
would be so much fun i thought well you
know i'm not gonna be able to produce
the main channel content in the same
quantity
uh by doing that we'd probably do three
episodes a week on the podcast or you
know so the podcast would do quite well
so i thought well if i build out a vlog
audience i could vlog the entire process
yes so that was the goal so that we
could do other things and travel but
still maintain that that presence and be
productive and work
so that was why um
i wish you the best of luck thank you so
much man really appreciate you coming on
is there anything else you want to
mention
thank you for spending so much time on
this uh
[Music]
what were you saying thank you to the
editor for spending no no
i thought you were trying to find that
editor he's alex right no his name is
not alex no it's andrew that's alex the
the editor is andrew oh why would i i do
why would you talk to the engineer i
don't know
moving on
gosh keep that in there andrew please
keep it don't keep it in there
andrew thank you for editing this
all right with that said andrew thank
you so much
and to the 200 000 viewers
expected thank you so much for watching
this i hope it wasn't a waste of your
time i hope you learned something and
type in the comment section where are
you in this spectrum right because it's
like really a spectrum on the gram side
and the jack side or the nice daily side
in terms of like you know uh uh uh uh
just normal stuff like everything we
discussed yeah that would be interesting
to see that make the comment interesting
interesting please the comment section
interesting that would be good thank you
guys so much for watching also make sure
to subscribe we'll link to your
information down below in the
description as well and while you're at
it get your free stock it's worth all
the way to a thousand dollars when you
sign up for public are you monetizing
them
you're monetizing your audience what
you're just sucking money out of your
audience and they get a free stock
technically they get a free stuff and
what do you get free stock you also get
a free stock free stock too
say if i buy an apple stock you get an
apple stock oh graham come on all right
until next time guys
he wanted to pull out what free stocks
he's got
don't open him up wait till he gets yeah
wait till he gets one that has a lot of
money
and then he's like see guys 35 dollars